lieu de monde c'est squeeze on serait
aujourd'hui dans un moment des bulles
avec squeeze épisode 3
arrêté à mousser m'a fait drôle quand
même alors premièrement je veux parler
d'un sujet qui va plus tout faire chier
à savoir le travail alors je décide de
parler de ce sujet parce que j'ai pas
mal de potes qui arrête pas de se
plaindre que tant les influences à
travailler que c'est à cause du temps
qui travaillent pas à machin alors c'est
simple au début j'y croyais et ça peut
être un bon prétexte une bonne excuse ou
quoi bon d'accord je veux bien y croire
mais au bout de six sept huit mois non
c'est plus possible et là j'ai fait une
terrible constatations quand il fait
beau les gens et disent ah ouais mec
cette viande rouge devant soleil d'or là
franchement j'ai tout sauf henry
travailler quoi faut profiter un peu du
temps et quand il fait manger les gens
qui disent ah
bon on ne travaille pas macho parce que
tu vois ton père d'assad le moral la
pressée pas envie de travailler rockets
mais [ __ ] merde à la fin vous et que
vous arrivez juste pas à travailler
c'est bon pas besoin de faire genre que
c'est de la faute du temps je suis pas
fou qu'est une pluie de météorites
dehors pour que je mette à bosser ou
comment ça se passe à
j-3 bord et quand bien même on arrive à
se mettre à travailler il ya toujours un
train de type prêté ce qui fait qu'on va
arrêter de bosser qu'est ce que c'est
chiant l'écho moi non mais là mon lit et
dans un de ces états a au nom mais j'ai
le devoir d'aller le ranger aller
[Musique]
non mais c'est quoi ça bordel
voilà pourquoi cette bouteille n'est pas
fermée
enfin bref maintenant moi ça me
désespère de travailler à temps me dis
pas que donc général préparation fille
stage en 1933 à
un moment début d'année squeeze 3o banon
va il faut pas que je loue quoi ah bah
bah c'est vraiment important c'est plus
important que les soirs à la seconde
chose j'aimerais vous parler dans cette
vidéo c'est le temps passé aux toilettes
en fait j'ai remarqué que selon l' objet
avec lequel tu va aux toilettes le temps
que tu es varie grandement par exemple
si tu vas avec un magazine le temps
passé sur le trône va durer en moyenne
dix minutes photos lettres au dac
[Musique]
toujours skylanders
non non ils ont pris vie depuis le
tiroir ils ont pris leurs portails et
ils sont mille ha
ha d'accord tu m'as fait peur j'ai cru
qu'ils étaient du genre de mec qui a
acheté les 43 skylander dalkia [ __ ]
j'ai eu peur en revanche si tu veux avec
ton [ __ ] de téléphones portables ils
ou le temps passe à 15 minutes ça
commence à faire long pour un kaka je
postais un cadre au charbon quelque
[Musique]
temps c'est quoi ces trois jours sur mon
bureau ah non non non c'est ça c'est ça
s'est poursuivi mais
essuyé quoi mais sûre s'il avait fallu
faire plus de jeu des prix pouvoir gros
pervers qui se masturbe pendant que
j'allais faire caca en fait mais en
revanche si tu trouve le moyen d'avoir
une console dans des toilettes là là le
ton est vraiment considérable jeux sean
mc pousse bien forage de temps dans
l'encrier
elle est même pas quoi je pense qu'en
mai au plus tard
je restais autant que ça aux toilettes
[ __ ] j'y retourne la troisième chose
dont je vous parlais dans ce moment des
vies lavez squeeze épisode 3 ça tombe
bien aujourd'hui on fait les choses
proprement alors c'est sûr fait d'une
cover la chanson what makes milliers ou
du cloud et foule des one direction
alors même si je dois admettre que je
suis pas vraiment un grand fan de ce
qu'ils font d'habitude là autant dire
que cette cover m'a vraiment mis sur le
cul la prochaine extrait de la vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait j'ai marqué un truc plutôt
plutôt chelou quand j'écoute cette
chanson je me mets à prendre un peu les
objectivement pour peu importe ce que
c'est et je pianote dessus comme si
c'est moi qui joue aussi bien que ces
mecs et en fait ça donne un truc que
apple moche
je vois tu la leyre non non
connaissez-vous cette émission bien
débile appelé les anges de la télé
réalité alors
bien sûr que oui et on a entendu parler
mais aujourd'hui je vais pas vous parler
des anges de la télé réalité mais des
anges des fps les anges des reflets ce
qu'est ce que c'est borodine l'émission
les anges de la télé réalité
alors qui cette parodie met en scène un
beau gosse de cheveux coiffés un
portugais qui regarde vers le ciel peu
gros beauf en train de rigoler une fret
bien mais qu'ils mangent pas sonné mais
c'est moi blonde client magazine en
mangeant sir ian e
vous et moi je veux dire elle est l
ultime discrètement la coke alors comme
dans les songes la diète grosse
embrouille d'ailleurs indiciels et
particulièrement merdique c4 le dire
tous ses tics apprentis et la chasse
et vous avez ce genre de personnes là
qui gueulent comptant aussi font chier
pour rien on a juste envie de les
stresse pas et c'est là que tu te diras
écrêté au sein de la maison et que la
mission va totalement partir en couille
et l'aurait placé à la première personne
et tout le monde doit survivre et sauver
sa peau bref je vous laisse un extrait
de quelques images et je vous laisse
aller voir le lire dans la description
si cette vidéo vous intéresse en dépit
des excuses épisode 3
non
mais